hello freak [ __ ] so the I said I
think maybe one of the most impressive
things or confusing or or unexpected was
how [ __ ] good GSP looked The Dude's
gone for four years comes back and
immediately I see him moving around and
popping the jab and I'm like Jesus
Christ he looks like GSP he now hold -
yeah yeah I see I wasn't I wasn't that
and everyone's like oh here's child the
hater no I wasn't that in love with
Jesus peas performance you weren't I
thought he looked good I thought he
looked heavy I didn't think he looked as
you know off he he put on some pounds
he's thick he was thick thick like a
musketeer thick
I thought he put on some pounds and his
cardio wasn't that great and get pretty
great for days before yeah he definitely
was suffering a little bit because of
that and also it has to be a big factor
for years off just the nerves and all
that huge factor and I struggled to hold
Bisping down Bisping's [ __ ] heart and
you know honestly taking him down was
one of the worst things that could
happen he got cut the [ __ ] up his Ben
didn't work down there and when I was
worried if it went to decision I thought
his beings actually winning even though
GSP got him down for that portion if the
if the hopefully the judges see that
Bisbing is doing the damage down oh for
sure that should count in their eyes I
agree I agree 100% the only time that's
ever really counted though in a fight is
Kevin Randleman versus bas Rutten
remember Kevin Randleman took bas Rutten
down but bas Rutten was beating the [ __ ]
out of him from the bottom and Randleman
dude and do anything but a lot of people
were super outraged after that decision
you know that was a weird one because
most of the fight was spent with boss on
the bottom and Randleman on top that's
old-school right I think I think JSP
obviously looked great passed the test I
didn't see I always look what's next I
didn't think I thought Bisbing was super
hesitant because for this reason they
trained earlier right they trained in
I guess 2006 so a while ago I guess GSP
just kind of mopped the floor with them
like kinda everyone so then I think just
peace camp and their thinking was
alright middleweights really not where
we should be at but Bisbing is kind of
easy pickings for us we might as well go
get the belt from here if we're gonna do
this big comeback so I think
he thought it was a good matchup and I
think because they trained prior that
wasn't normal Bisbing Bisbing pushes the
pace I think he was so worried about the
takedown like Felice so I don't think
that Bisbee they look great to me either
no he looked very super hesitant and
stiff and he looked like you know father
times like yo man tonight tonight I
don't think it was a father time thing I
think it was in the back of his mind me
he was very openly admitting that GSP
dominated those training sessions they
had in 2006 and he was saying look I'm
much better than I was back then which
I'm sure he is but you can only get so
much better it's not so a mental thing
yeah I got tan when he did that and he's
impossible to get off so yeah I think he
was very reserved but I just I thought
again I thought after four years hell
yeah George Lee good did George look
good enough to beat like a Whitaker or
yo Romero probably not not to hate on
his not to hate on what's going on right
now because the epic night I just look
at the real middleweights yearning
Whitaker
Yoel Luke Rockhold yeah remember those
cardio problems I was like this was a
fun one and you're crazy if you think
he's gonna fight again iv5 that didn't
happen I don't think so either I can
promise you that's not happening I think
he drops right back down and once this
fight and Woodley next yeah when I was
thinking about him fighting and
Woodley's no [ __ ] picnic that's not a
cakewalk a good matchup wise it's very
tough for GSP well you know Woodley's
been dealing with a shoulder injury he
hurt his shoulder pretty bad in that
fight early in the Thompson fight and so
what he does about that is what that
that that's what that's what's up in the
air if he chooses to have surgery I
believe he has know if he's talked about
it but I think he has a labrum tear so
as the question is what he decides to do
about that I heard him say about Colby
coming to him we should talk about him
he's killing me but yeah but in a good
way but he was saying he goes yeah my
shoulders messed up but it's good enough
where I could whoop Colby's ass now is
it good enough to whoop TSB probably not
but Whitaker's out - yeah if you recurse
almost back if they do another intern
belt that bad welterweight I'm gonna
bust I'm gonna freak out if there's more
intern belt I'm afraid the [ __ ] out they
do they do well if wood let's do surgery
and then GSP live in Covington oh my god
or GSB verse someone down there
GSP or someone would get a lot of press
yep they think they got over a million
pay-per-view buys Saturday night I hope
so yeah I hope so
I thought I thought it was gonna do
around 700 they might have got a million
just from Canada
they said Canada was tracking higher
than the papacy pay-per-view for
Mayweather vs McGregor really yeah
Canada come on man it's crazy for GSP
burn love them some GSP I mean he won a
fleet of the year back in the UFC was
like not nearly as popular it's true
he's blue Ronda and pre Conor he won
athlete of the year well now I'll see
there's the Conor McGregor effect but
there's no one you'll see you can go to
Canada and sell out the Bell Center you
know John Trump now you can do that his
next fight you can go up there and do
this oh my god his next fight now he's
the middleweight champion the world holy
[ __ ] Jesus Christ you know in his
contract and Dana said this but
contractor like pinky swears in the OSI
they're kind of like guy whatever you
know I'm saying I think you know in his
contract he has and he said this and
it's in his contract he has to defend
the middle for the middleweight title
but again I don't think it's gonna
happen
did you hear if Freddie Roach talked
about how eighty five is not where he
wants to be at when they asked him
what's next and also remember it all
this adds up it's easy to figure out
enough to be [ __ ] Sherlock Holmes
Whitaker was cage side if that fight was
next the way you rip your promo is bring
Whitaker into the cage they're like nah
son you're good you sit there you ain't
coming in here we don't need that right
now
it's definitely open yeah I don't know
man Whitaker I'm sure would want that
fight hell yeah I'd want that fight I
don't think GSP was ever really
considering it no I don't it's just not
a possibility
I think Julie's next but yeah injured
here's the real question question if
Connor defends against Tony and that's a
big fight which I heard is a March
that's the rumors a lot of things have
to happen lineup so cocky little weight
which I think he's down to do he was a
gorilla when I interviewed him at the
weigh-ins and I put my arm on I was like
it's too
[ __ ] dude he's giant it's too much it
was just too much it was like huge yeah
it's just he's way bigger like he looked
like 200 plus pounds when he got its
frames so much bigger than Connor but
just the magnitude of that fight they do
that a catchweight
that's a super fight when we talk about
super fights nothing [ __ ] superfine
he'd have to be 170 but if they did do
it at 170 Connor would have to get
through Tony he's gonna have to beat
Woodley then you get an end of next year
there's a lot left to line up cuz Connor
beaten it yeah Tony what giant hit even
if he doesn't it's still super fight
right if he loses by devastating
knockout it's not a super-fun yeah you
know you're not gonna see GSP again you
know the thing about Woodley is if
Woodley wins you're probably going to
the hospital unless your name's
wonderboy well probably going to sleep
yeah and the couches the fan
well wonder but wonder boy fight at
least Wentz a decision but there was
moments in that fight where it looked
like Wonder Boy was going out hell yeah
I mean Woodley puts people excuse me
what he puts people to sleep I mean he
it's [ __ ] hard but here's the
question like what how much damage has
been done to his shoulder and what what
needs to be mean it's a labrum tear
whatever sort of a tear it is can it be
fixed with stem cells can it be fixed
with rehab or is it damaged to the point
where he's gonna need surgery because if
he does he's likely out a year that's
what Kane had Kane had labrum surgery
turns out for a year it's a rough one to
determine yeah it's not it's not an easy
road back and especially excuse me
you're someone who has that wild
punching style like Woodley thinking
about how much [ __ ] torque that guy
puts in his punches and he might be the
heaviest hitter in the history of 170
pound division you watched that fight
with Josh Koscheck or watch that fight
with Jay here on
[Applause]
[Music]